luno the fastest easiest way to buy crypto if
you're just getting into bitcoin it's the perfect
place to start hey guys wanna welcome back to
my show it is powered by icon plus as usual
so a quick news announcement for you so binazz
has just joined icon as a public representative
and made it possible for its users to stake icx
on binance and earn up to 21.79 interest so that's
pretty cool now a quick shout out to block by
they are my sponsors i use them to add up to 8.6
interest on my usdc you can actually get 250
dollars um up to that when you sign up so i
think that's pretty cool now before i bring
on my guest because things are going to get
kind of i'm going to say heated because she's
a pretty interesting guest um i want to give
a quick shout out to coinflip they also sponsor
the show so you can get 10 off transactions there
so when you buy bitcoin so i'm gonna leave a
link for you rolling somewhere at the bottom
now if you are watching on youtube please
don't forget to hit the like button and hit
subscribe so you never miss any of these
fantastic guests now joining me today
is uh somebody who's doing some pretty interesting
stuff in the blockchain industry and in the crypto
space in general it is of course adrian ashley
how are you doing i am doing amazing how are you
i'm good it's great to have you it's great to
be it's great to be back in your show i always
enjoy your show you're just you're phenomenal and
i'm i'm glad that you're actually going bigger
oh well thank you i appreciate that so for those
that don't know you i really want you to explain
what you do i think it's best coming from you
because you're a bit of a you're quite fiery and
exotic and exciting so you you tell us who you
are so i'm uh i'm a little bit of a bitcoin og
i got in in 2009 uh didn't really know what
i was doing lost my wallet with 2500 bitcoin
in it kind of got back in around 2011 2012 and
launched lolly in 2015 so we solved the me too
epidemic by putting consent on the blockchain
and my little pithy quote about what do you do
i have a naughty dating app for good girls that
gets women laid so that's basically what we do
because women need safety security and certainty
to say yes the blockchain provides identity
verification it provides that consent certainty
so there's no go backseas so it kind of does
everything that we women need in order for us to
feel confident to even go to dinner okay so that's
a lot and i love it and it's really cool and it's
really different so i want to go back a second so
you have a dating app called lolly and it's
on the ethereum blockchain is that right so
yes at the moment it is on the ethereum blockchain
although we are going to be moving to e2 because
obviously eth1 my concern i was actually gonna
completely switch blockchains but uh because i
i didn't want to get a hit with crypto kitties
where a five dollar cup of coffee cost you 45
in gas and with our whole reputation and staking
system the whole point is you know that it's it's
stable it's an unpumpable token it's not meant to
be i ico'ed and then pumped to five bucks and then
drop down to a penny which you know so a lot of
investors are like oh we can't pump it i'm like
yeah no it's not meant to do that it's actually
a real utility because i don't want to sell a
security because that'll look good in orange
no absolutely not so talk to me about this
app how does it work so i look i tried to get
it on my iphone but i wasn't sure that i could
so you can't it's not out and we actually just
had someone release a dating app called lolly so
we're in negotiations at right now and we are
probably going to change our name okay so can
you tell take me through how this is going to look
what can we expect from a from an app that helps
women date that how that helps put consent on the
blockchain how is this gonna look so basically you
know what normal dating apps right they're chock
full of bots fake profiles like eharmony it's all
sign up for free right well yeah you sign up for
free but you can't actually do anything for free
except build your profile and then if you want to
delete your profile you can't actually do that you
can cancel but that doesn't delete your profile to
delete your profile you actually have to google to
get a very hidden unnavigatable link to actually
delete your content so there's a lot of people who
aren't actually live on platforms so our platform
is different in that everyone is actually real and
we're doing that by launching the consent piece
first so it's not a dating app to begin with
because it's just the consent you gotta find your
own target but once we get enough people in each
city then we'll roll out the dating portion of
it in each city so that's how we're going to
make sure that it's actually real people because
most dating apps launch with a test set of data
which doesn't help you date because they're not
really there yeah exactly and i too many stories
i've heard about people getting catfished um
people not showing up and all these things but
when you say consent on the blockchain i still
don't understand okay so you know how sometimes
you go to dinner and the guy thinks because you
went to a steak dinner that that means he gets sex
you've heard of that yeah of course often women
are afraid to let a man pay for dinner because
she feels like she owes him something afterwards
exactly so this way you can consent just to dinner
if you do through the app through the app yep
you're just like it's it's what it does is it
inspires transparent communication what do
we really do in here right it's also good
for things like if you're dating somebody in the
workplace and your workplace has policies that
says you can't date anybody in the workplace the
reason they have those policies is to eliminate
the risk of sexual harassment claims right so
this way you can use the app and say yes this
is a consensual relationship but where before
we have to actually go to human resources and
fill out the darn form and tell them right but
it is consensual and then when it comes time to
actually have sex you open a consent window
because here's the other thing there are
a lot of uh very faulty consent applications
out there they don't do anything their single
point of consent they don't really verify the
identity of the person and it's not very explicit
so ours actually opens a consent window
um you guys agree it it literally has like
like how naughty can i get we're not on
broadcasting do it no do what you want
go for it yeah yeah go for it okay well this
will go on youtube and i don't youtube to
get any strikes against me okay so how about this
i'm gonna i'm just gonna i'm gonna use innuendo
do it and if i think if i think you can go
further then i'll i'll push it further okay
uh you know how there's a percentage of girls who
are like totally fine with having the back door
doorbell yeah yeah right well some girls are
that would probably be good to know for the guy
before things get started whether or not that's
an option okay so you would put all of this
on the blockchain and confirm it and make sure
everybody knows what's happening well no because
see everybody isn't going to know everything
because the whole point is these consent will
never end up on the cover of tmz it's multi-sig
it's not it's not something that you can just
pull um the only way you can actually get
the data or heaven forbid something go wrong
and you use your safe word and it starts streaming
the audio to our secure servers they're not even
ours they're the community secure servers and
they're run by lawyers in all 50 states so
you can't get it without a court order or law
enforcement like it's not for tmz it's not to
both parties know what's happening everybody if
you and i were to go on a date for example we'd
put an agreement in and then both parties would
know what's happening exactly and then at the end
of the date or your time together then you close
the consent window and then your rating if it if
it was a match that we set up you would be rating
how compatible you were how accurate the profile
was things like that so these ratings are never
actually for public they're only to train the ai
and then when we do the dating piece we have
what's called a heat index and it's like how
compatible are you and a 5 is basically fabulous
for a one night stand pretty compatible both of
you are awesome people but one of you is just
really not not really good for long term or you
have some kind of significant core value mismatch
which would make long term not really viable
right so like you want kids and he never wants
kids that would be a core value mismatch that
doesn't mean you can't have fun in vegas for
a weekend but probably not gonna get married
and what we found is that most women really
want long-term love and they said it at an
8.5 and above on the heat index you're only ever
rated as you would be a couple you're never rated
individually because that's not what it's about
right we're not making judgment we say there's
a pot for there's a lid for every pot right so
there is a match out there and so if you set it
for an 8.5 it's only gonna show you people who
would be long-term compatible but if you set it
down to a five which our focus group does probably
three to five times a year usually after midnight
and a lot of times when they're out of town this
is actually how the entire app was created was
at two o'clock in the morning in a las vegas
hotel room when i was alone horny and had no
solution to my problem i remember you telling
me this yes and then yeah go for it oh my big
brother uh my my big brother in social media
joel crom uh basically kicked my butt for six
months and said no you can't you can't make a
hookup app this you you cannot make a hookup
i was like but dude we need a hookup app and
he's like no you don't women want love they want
marriage they want it it's both it's not just a
hookup app it well it started off as a hookup app
my button made me do a focus group and so i
did the focus group and lo and behold as usual
he was right yeah i think so because i i don't
think women like entirely want a hookup app
i think being able to have both choices is
definitely going to reach a bigger audience
well it would be like what if eharmony which is
you know that it is literally designed for and
marketed as the marriage app gave you an option
to press a button and magically uh you know a
nice stud muffin with a six-pack and talent shows
up okay they have a question on this point though
are actually okay with they want an app that
they're not embarrassed to have on their phone
that actually has the secret functionality that
every now and again they can just lower that
and go who's i have a question on that exact point
okay so i so i remember we had this conversation
i think it was over a year ago or something like
that and you were sort of saying you know you were
in vegas or whatever and you were in a hotel room
and you're alone and you just wanted to have an
app whereby you could just get somebody delivered
to the door basically that not just like anyone
not just anyone but but somebody who would assume
what you wanted yes appropriate but but how likely
are they to you need to have the amount of people
on the app to find that right so you need to have
enough users so how can you guarantee that you're
gonna actually have have someone for everyone on
an app i believe there's something for everyone in
the world but how you do you believe that you're
going to get that exact person because that's what
you guys do right you mark it on being able to
get that person which is why we're not starting
with the dating app that's why we're starting
with the consent app because that's you find your
own targets which we were going to release last
valentine's day and then hello coven so basically
killed our launch last year and so now we're we're
rebooting we're rebranding um like i said we had
a little trademark issue and since they're already
out and i'm not an [ __ ] uh it's easier for
me to change my name than them to change theirs
we'll see how enough we'll see how it goes
but so you have an augmented reality feature
yes so talk me through this what does that mean so
when okay so i go to a lot of conferences and at
these conferences you know there'll be 500 people
in a in a ballroom right at a cocktail party well
i really if i'm interested in you know fun then i
don't need to meet 500 people so you can actually
hold it up and anybody else who's on the app
it will show you and it'll give you like the
color-coded heat index so that you can tell this
is a hot target or a cold target oh wow i see
so oh wow that is insanely futuristic wait so
you're saying the app knows what you want as
an individual whether it's for a night or whether
it's for a long time and you're in a room of over
hundreds even thousands maybe of people but that
but wouldn't that assume that they're already on
the app it would they would have to be on the
app yes right so this is the you tell the app
what you want the more transparent you are the
more honest you are and this is the big thing
with women when i ask them you know what do you
really want i've got tissue all over the room
because i know a good portion of the room
is about to burst into tears they honestly
don't know what they want and and i think it's
funny because i'm kind of a i'm a badass type a
very control freak very driven very
ambitious i'm really hard to date like
really hard and then what i what i always find
funny is i'm actually not that hard if you just
understand that i grew up on smutty romance novels
in disney movies then you'll know exactly what i
want in a man right i want to be swept off my
feet i want every woman right but i want to have
um i want to have i want i want confident
competence does that make sense competency oh yeah
competence is the most attractive quality i don't
want to drive all the i don't always want to be
the one to drive i want to be able to take my
phone yes and and no we're still going to get
there and everything's taken care of it's like
when i go on vacation with my girlfriends right
we're all the same which is hilarious because
people are like how can that many taipei control
freak women like travel together and like it's
so easy and just get on everything is handled
somebody somebody literally steps up so we really
only have to take care of maybe ten percent
of what we generally we're at a hundred percent
so ninety percent of the time we're like oh god
this is so relaxing right so that's what we look
for in men we want to know that they that they
can handle things without us having to oversee
it's really interesting because somebody's just
written in the comments you won't attract an alpha
male with that attitude but i really disagree and
the reason i disagree is because men i think i
think the person may be watching misunderstood
because you're not saying that you want to be the
alpha in the relationship you're saying you want
to switch off you want to let him be the alpha i
need someone who can out alpha me i need someone
who is like i look at that person and i'm just
like oh my goodness okay my man right like
i want to sink into my feminine which is almost
impossible with most people like it's just it's
very difficult but like i said is if if they would
just read like 10 smutty romance novels watch the
hallmark channel for a weekend and maybe like
four or five disney princess movies they would
totally get what a lot of women need and yeah i
think there's like this misunderstanding between
like ambitious women because there are some women
who i think are impossible because they won't let
their man be a man or you know they want to be in
control and i totally understand why that doesn't
work but there's this misunderstanding that career
women there's i think there's an idea that career
women want to be in charge in a relationship
and most of us absolutely don't no way you drive
you don't i don't want to honey i will i i
will literally make sure that you never leave
the house hungry or horny absolutely that is my
duty as your woman got it i'm good with that i
i absolutely love to take care of my man and i
do not want to be the alpha in the relationship
i like that but because of who i am and how
people usually meet me because i am such an
alpha in public and in business it's hard to do
that transition because most of the time i don't
meet anybody unless i'm in that environment yeah i
get that i guess you know you can especially with
work that's where a lot of people end up meeting
their other half yeah and you're constantly in
alpha mode when you're working so it's harder
to yeah put that that femininity forward maybe
yeah so okay so your app in order to work needs
to have all of these people to pick from like you
said this augmented reality feature it needs
to have all all the guys all the women signed
up so everybody's in sync and knows what's
what so with that in mind how do you then
the great bronze you go from singles parties so
everyone has already signed up for the app that
goes to the singles parties so oh i say okay right
so in a general conference like a just a like web
summit or some other conference with 70 000 100
thousand people um it's not gonna be as effective
but for the singles parties that we have on the
roadmap that we've set up that works because
everybody has the app their app is fully
filled out and then when they check in
our people actually validate and give them
like almost like a look score kind of like
they look at their their application they look at
their their profile and like how accurate is it
so it's not like it's not like
saying you know this guy's a
you know a nine on a scale of one to ten it's
you know how accurate is the profile compared
to the human being standing in front of me yeah
you're a nine f he's a nine for you basically
but it's not even the nine for me again
remember nobody scored individually it's
really how accurate is the profile compared to
the human because the guy oh i miss that song
i could be a six right look scale in my opinion
you know in in my biased perspective i could i
could consider him a six right but if his profile
is super accurate that would actually give him a
higher score oh understood okay so no cat fishing
then basically that eliminates the catfishing
it eliminates the catfishing and there's a whole
bunch of things that we do that that uh increase
the safety standards and those are the reasons
why we do things the way that we do even though
people are like that's a pain in the butt you're
gonna have trouble onboarding i'm like no i'm not
i think okay i'm getting this yeah wait so
you have a token you also have a token though
yes because that's the reputation and staking
system so explain that why are we having a
staking well i understand i guess because it's a
blockchain and everything needs to be validated
and the consent needs to be validated but gone
well the consent that's that's easy the consent
piece getting validated that's already i mean that
smart contract is already done that's super super
easy but the reputation and staking right so a
man's worst fear is that she's going to be fat
in a woman's worst fears she's
going to be murdered how do you yeah
both sides equation right no really and this
is multiple polls over the last five years
and i'm like i'm not really worried about being
murdered and then i thought about it i go yeah
i don't really go out so that would be why i'm
not worried about getting murdered so okay so the
the reputation and staking system is is critical
because people need to vouch now the other piece
of this that's the sneaky fun part is your
parents can vouch for you your parents aren't
necessarily single there are people on the app who
are not necessarily single they're actually there
as as almost like matchmakers as helpers right
they're the the friends because the other fun
part is you know you're single friends
of friends some of my best when i drop my
original hinge had it right i would drop my pin
down in silicon valley and it and i'm friends with
billionaires and it would be all their single
friends and i'm like i'm still friends with
five of the guys that i met on hinge back when it
actually worked because i don't think it works now
um and it was awesome because these were the
friends of people that i actually know and adore
so of course i'm gonna have a better affinity
with them in the first place right yeah no
that makes sense yeah so so the the staking
piece of it is you know you have people that
they'll they'll show up they'll take one
look at her and they'll leave and they
and they won't even they'll just ghost right
like that person their stake would be forfeited
uh they they wouldn't they would they would lose
their money but they would also lose their friends
money okay so i'm not i'm not getting the staking
part though i'm not getting the staking part so
to to in order to use the apps you have to stay a
certain amount of money no explain okay so people
can like say you put your profile picture up right
your friends can go oh that is a that is a recent
picture of her i'm going to stake that right
and and they actually earn rewards for vouching
or statements it's the gamification of the
app with the tokens where they can use the
toke they can use the tokens for in-app purchases
they can also earn tokens by staking it's almost
like interest um but we're doing everything to
avoid any sec complications so it's it's all
gamification and rewards and loyalty and things
like that and then what kind of things can you
use to buy with the tokens what features can
you unlock by background checks you can upgrade
to voyer mode where you can seek but not be found
we have like 50 different things that you can buy
wow this is a yeah which is why we're starting
with a consent app because to build the full app
is two and a half million dollars which we need
to fundraise for to build the consent app less
and once we launch that then the user id piece
we can also also incorporate into a lot of other
applications that have nothing to do with dating
but also confirm this is a real human being and
include the reputation and staking so it should
replace a lot of the default logins because it'll
just be a simple apk and the different websites
that use it will actually earn rewards themselves
it's kind of like you don't get anything for
using the google login or the facebook login you
know for the social login but say you're a website
owner and you put this on there you actually earn
rewards almost like affiliate commissions
every time people sign up using this
because it brings them into the ecosystem
so okay with all of that in mind then
so i understand that like normal dating apps
i don't i don't use them i don't like them i
don't want them um personally i just i don't
know i just find this change i use no i'm not
every quarter oh okay every every quarter on a
sunday night usually about 10 30 11 o'clock at
night and then i spend a couple hours swiping and
then uh and then i ghost the apps again so then i
log back in there like are you here i'm like dude
you got to get me i'm only on the app for five
minutes like you got to get me like right then
but like these apps i don't really think they're
particularly romantic anyway right like tinder
is just a hookup app at this point i don't think
it's romantic but my question to you is do you
think having to lock in these things and sort of
make that contract on the blockchain of what you
want out of this specific date sort of number one
takes away the romance and then number two kind of
takes away any potential for any spontaneity and
so on and so on well if you're just saying you're
consenting for dinner you can always upgrade it
okay you can upgrade you oh heck yeah you can one
flick no problem you both go but isn't that but it
is isn't that like really like black mirror have
you seen black mirror do you know black mirror
yeah i'm laughing because where do you think they
came up with the episode oh is that from you guys
that's the question from what i understand
it's like friend of a friend of a friend
i can trace it so pretty have you seen the
episode yes so it's just oh i don't know
like because they were a lot they they
had an expiration date like they had to go
through that like hardship together yeah
despite the expiration date so here's the thing
we have we have an issue with people you know
like this one girl on tinder as an example
specifically said i'm not here for hookups
i'm not sleeping with you guy asks her out
right covid says why don't you come to my house
for dinner she goes to his house i'm like coveted
or not covered woman you should be meeting in the
park socially distanced six feet apart each of you
on your own picnic blanket what the heck are
you thinking and she never met this guy before
no and she goes to his house and he literally
mansplained her why she was supposed to sleep
with him because those are the rules even though
she has in her thing that she's not having sex
there's there's so much well that's
very silly of heads i have to say
uh there's so much assumption right right
so this makes everything more clear and yes
there's a way to make it sexy and i i don't want
to go into the entire marketing campaign of how
we're going to do that but i'll just tell you
i have history because in uh in the 80s and 90s
i got people to use condoms which they didn't
want to do but could save their life so this is
not my first rodeo getting people to do what they
don't necessarily want to do that's good for them
so i can i i got that part down it'll be
i'm excited yeah i mean i'm excited to see
how you guys do i just wondered have you had
much have you had much backlash about this
um i mean i've been reading the comments
they're pretty interesting because i think
initially people sort of said that's a very
shallow idea um but i but it's not just a hookup
app it's it's both it's a long-term love app as
well so i just wonder if you've had much backlash
it uh no not really so i did i just saw
that there uh that there are yeah we can
let's read them but not my type of women well
here's the thing not manipulative because the
one thing this is is transparent that's the
whole point so a lot of women are manipulative
because they're playing the game this is more
of here's exactly what i'm looking for here's my
core values here's the best part though when you
fill out this and the ai knows exactly what you're
looking for it is not going to show you somebody
inappropriate so you're not swiping through
thousands of profiles especially thousands of
fake profiles like when i first uh got on bumble
where i live trust me i'm in reno nevada
there are not 50 hedge fund managers and
venture capitalists here they might have at some
point in history on tinder went skiing in tahoe
but they were definitely not living in reno
right the app was telling me matter of fact
i i screenshotted um my friend's boyfriend i got
so mad i was like dude what the [ __ ] like i was
so pissed because here's my friend's boyfriend
and they live together and he's on bumble except
he's never i think he's never been on bumble
it was his seven years prior tinder profile
that was on bumble that was on bumble oh that's
terrible that's actually really bad that's really
really bad because that can ruin relationships
if you know it's already quite a rocky one like
i i i'm in my 20s but when i was maybe like 18
i used to go on some of the dating apps and i
think i don't think my profile is even removed
i don't haven't had the apps in years and um
i remember i sent i uh somebody sent me a
screenshot in my instagram dms and was like
is this you on tinder and so i sent it to
my boyfriend at the time and i was just like
i was like this i'm not on tinder if anyone
says i want tinder i was like i'm not
it's it's just my profile's on there i don't know
why it's on there must be from when i was like
17 or 18 or whatever um yeah i don't know how to
take it down apparently it's still on there um you
can't they they make it almost impossible to take
it down right so you have to basically download
the app log in and then just say hide my profile
because deleting the file is near impossible
what would you say some of the biggest issues
with these dating apps are then and that you're
trying to trying to solve uh fake people
30 of the guys that ask me out are married
oh that happens on twitter as well by the way on
social media it's quite unbelievable oh yes and
only 10 of them say i'm ethically not monogamous
i go great that is wonderful i'm so happy that
you've got that figured out i am ethically not
monogamous what does that mean polyamorous it
means i write polyamorous okay ethically not
monogamous okay i've not had it put that way
yes so so those are the key pieces is that
you really need to have transparency and
what do you really want you need to be honest
with yourself what do you really want right
and once you put that in there then the a
then the ai can help but how we're getting
it out there in the first place is we're having
this conversation about me too right you either
have consent or you don't period right so you
are not gonna win a sexual harassment defense
if you don't have consent because you've got all
the data proving it from the app essentially right
so your only defense is going to be affirmative
consent because right now it's he said she said
and and here's the problem because i'm not letting
women off the hook i'm not saying men are all bad
and i'm not saying oh i know plenty of awful women
that have accused men of terrible things um i will
just i will just go back to me in my 20s and i am
not a horrible person okay but i can totally see
how some women go over the edge so in my
20s i would go to a club i would meet a guy
i had pretty much planned
our wedding within 15 minutes
down time go come on do you know how common this
is no i'm not like that we literally future pace
because we're not gonna actually date somebody
or sleep with somebody that we wouldn't marry
right so okay go on keep going oh i've
pretty much planned the wedding where we're
gonna live how many kids we're gonna have
you know the pets the whole the whole bit
before i say yes and go home
with them and have sex with them
then it you know it'll last a week two
weeks three weeks whatever and then
and then uh it fizzles out or whatever and then i
cry for a week and then wash rinse repeat again uh
but but some women uh the next when when it
does fizzle out or the next day would be like
oh well i would never actually just have sex with
someone just to have sex with someone because it's
cognitive dissonance they would never do that
they they were going to marry this person that's
why they had sex with them so if they're not
going to marry them then it must have been rape
you would not believe how many times
terrible that's terrible really so
it's it's a problem so wait are you saying are you
saying these women because they're i they're what
they sort of planned in their head for the
future didn't happen they didn't consent to
having sex without the future that without getting
married basically correct so that's not correct
so right so it protects men from that and
it protects women from you know because she
can just be like i do not consent right and you
know hopefully we can get this spread out enough
where so the other thing is like in texas it is a
third class misdemeanor and a 500 fine to send an
unsolicited dick pic i'm waiting for this to get
everywhere i love that we could get that in the uk
that's all you see my dms are terrible oh right i
only saved three out of you why did you say that
because they were really good i was like oh
uh oh yeah okay that yeah i saved it i say
in a private locker they're not very public
but yeah three out of thousands past muster
for that was worth sending so the other piece
is you know if you want to send somebody
a an explicit photo you need consent right you
should at least they sent it through the app
they they after they have consent they could uh
i say or or they have consent and then they can
send it however they want it but then you need to
be able to revoke consent when it's like you know
what i'm no longer interested in you revoke
boom very interesting i'm really interested
to see how this plays out and how it works um
just because of how much sort of okay dialogue
it sort of requires i find that really
fascinating to see how that's going to play
out do you see what i mean when i say dialogue
you mean like role-playing like like no no yes
like how direct you have to be about what you
want what they want i don't know everything
it's it's in the you put that in the here's the
thing women oh you don't speak no talking okay
do you know how how old i was when i first
opened my mouth and said can you do this
and then he did it and then my mind blew
i remember you telling me this i was 50.
50. okay so women don't say anything while naked
and asked for what i wanted like and that's common
we would literally we hit 50 and then we
just we're like what the [ __ ] why not
like right the ability to speak and ask for what
we want is great so anyways that makes up for that
yeah it's all on the app okay so you basically put
in so if you look at adult friend finder it's the
most honest app right but i don't know it what is
it it's is it what it says it is it's a naughty
swingers hook up naked you know but you
can walk in and you are literally as a
woman bombarded by a wall of [ __ ] shots
and that is not how we choose right like
and if your smile shoots joy out of your eyes i
want to see that first because you know if you're
like a horrible human even if you have a great
dick that's a no for me that's right so it's
not how we choose so but it is honest because it
does show what you like and what you're interested
in and what you're looking for and people are
ridiculously honest on that app and i'm like
what if you could have mainstream people be just
as honest but it not be publicly disclosed so
this is why we use the ai because the ai does the
matching like i don't know what you want that's
in your that's the other piece of the blockchain
that's in your id right when it goes to do the
matching it's matching you but it's only looking
at you you are giving it permission to look
like i can't just log in and see you know your
sexual preferences that's that's not how it works
right but when it's matching you together and
when you're doing the consent what it'll show
you is it'll highlight any mismatches right
okay it keeps that organic anticipation
kind of you know surprise because it's only gonna
call out like and i'll just give you an example so
um this guy had been pursuing me for a year
and i finally i finally said yes to coffee
and then we went to dinner or whatever and
then you know like three months into it
find out we're we're not really competing he
was pretty good about one thing like you can't
choke me like i was hung for witchcraft in a
previous life you touch my neck i'm gonna kick
your ass i can hold my own damn breath i get the
idea of being choked don't like it don't do it
he's like he could live with that but he wanted me
to call him daddy i can't do that i have a child
i'm just not i'm not that's i ca it i dry up every
time he wants me to call him daddy i'm like i
no i can't so i can't date him right and that
would be on and basically that preference
would be on the app so you wouldn't have even
needed to be in that situation you're saying
right because he never would have actually been
ex i would have never seen him because he would
never have been populated in the app because
there is this there is a a critical mismatch
that i i mean i haven't i'm not calling
you daddy it ain't never gonna happen ever
right i do find that really weird
if i'm honest that is a hard no
what did you say i do find that really weird
i'm with you i find that really really weird
it's i i can't i just can't right and and
he doesn't have kids so he doesn't get it
but everybody that i've talked to who has kids
they're like oh ooh no i was like right i can't
and i get it but i i can't that's my personal
thing and here's the other thing the app
no judgment right everybody has their own
kinks their own quirks like i said there's
a lid for every pot i'm not actually making any
judgments no children no animals no relatives
there you go i say that's pretty damn
liberal right no i think yeah i i think
i think it's really interesting and like
i said i'm just really excited to see
how it takes how it takes off and then also
because this is obviously using the ethereum
blockchain how do you think people outside of the
space will fare in terms of getting involved in
this do you think they might feel oh no that's
blockchain technology i i don't understand yeah
that's so that was the big thing is people like oh
i don't get blockchain so i'm not gonna do it i'm
like right you're not gonna know it do you know
how your email works you use your email every day
all the time do you know how email works
no it's all about the ux right so we hide
the mechanics and they only see the user interface
and that's super easy and very familiar which is
how we're driving blockchain adoption into the
mainstream because it's a dating app everybody
knows what a dating app is it's easy this is
such an interesting topic um i've been reading
through the comments as we've been talking and
i'm just finding the response is really really
interesting one person says that's terrifying to
me um somebody else says i miss the old days where
you would go up to a woman and compliment her now
everything is digital very sad i do agree i i i'm
very old school and very traditional i miss the
old days where men would come up and compliment me
you miss it too i i miss like okay i walk
through the world and if i see a woman who's
got a nice outfit on i like her shoes i like
her hair whatever i compliment her why because
nobody is complimenting anybody anymore so i do
it all the time every opportunity i possibly can
because i just know it's not happening yeah just
on that point a few years ago before covert when
we were allowed outside um i i saw a girl i live i
was living in london at the time and i saw a girl
on the train and she had the most unbelievable
shoes they were stunning and i had to tell her
so i told her i said i was like wow your shoes are
unbelievable and she just thought like i was going
to like stab her or something she just gave me a
terrible look yeah it's really interesting it's
really interesting how you know complimenting
someone is almost the most uh terrifying thing
for people because it's so uncommon and then i
also think just you mentioned the metoo campaign
i also think off the back of that a lot of
men are sort of afraid so something that
something that was really interesting so the
actor henry cavill so if anyone's if anyone
doesn't know who he is he's the guy who plays
superman um anyway he he's gorgeous and i and
he's single i believe um and he basically made
a comment during the metoo campaign and he said
he's afraid to approach a woman now because he
feels like he's traditional when a woman should be
um she should be um pursued and he feels like
he'll be told off for sexual harassment anyway
the metoo movement was very angry about that but i
think he has a point i i think he absolutely has a
point he absolutely has a point literally this is
what the app solves okay okay if you are a woman
and you are interested in a man you basically
give that man the green light to compliment you
ask you out because you're you're basically
acknowledging yes i'm interested in being pursued
i see i see it's oh gosh it's an interesting
one that that sort of push and pull between
a natural romance versus giving the green
light but it's necessary because i feel
like on both ends men are at risk women are
at risk so it's kind of come down to that
right it's terrible it's the fact that it's this
it's very dystopian right yes it is dystopian
and i'm sorry i didn't create this culture i'm
just trying to solve it and make it a little bit
more seamless so that great people can literally
just you know click i like this person and it's
green lighter note and if it's a green light then
they can they can pursue and it does they don't
have to pursue on the app if they know the person
yeah there you go i think you hit the nail on the
head though is it because the comments are really
interesting and i think i think that the response
in general is going to be really interesting
people will feel that this is dystopian but
it's kind of something which has come off
the back of a culture that's already grown
coming to come into light i'm not sure the best
word to use for that for that one but something
i really wanted to tell you actually um so when
we did our first interview i think it was over
a year ago when we were doing it so we were in a
much more formal setting so i was in a news room
um i had it was also quite late in my time so it
was just me and then i had a couple of guys in the
um control room and starting to take anyway they
heard everything and you were far more but you you
were far more um explicit then which is good which
is good i'm just honestly i'm pleased you weren't
now because i don't think we've handled it but
back then you were so explicit and i just i just
remember being in such a formal setting and just
sort of thinking you're asking me you were like do
you know you you're sort of like um oh sometimes
i feel i feel this way do you know what i mean
leia and i was like i'm at work stop it well it
was really interesting it's it's very funny so
um you know every time i do a pitch competition or
every time i you know i i talk and you know talk
about what i'm what i'm working on and talk about
the app they're like are you a stand-up comic
and i was like okay so i need to do a pitch
competition after dark at a comedy club with booze
because i think then people would actually get
it better i really agree with you yeah yeah
i think so i think because like it is dystopian
yeah um someone just goes this is insanity what's
wrong with women um this is just a reaction
okay no no no no no no wait no no no no no
i am equal opportunity let me explain to you a
date i had where i said we can meet in public
for coffee and he's like okay well meet me at
the gas station because where we're going is
a little hard to find so i meet him at the gas
station i'm not sure what the [ __ ] is going on
and he should we go around i follow him in the car
did it to a parking lot and i think we're gonna go
to a coffee shop now i think he's just leaving his
car there he gets in my car and i i start to drive
off he goes where are you going and i'm like where
are we going he goes we're here i'm like what do
you mean we're here i said public coffee he goes
this is public it's the post office parking lot
and i go i said we could meet in public for
coffee he goes oh no i don't do that and
i have a taser and mace in my side door and i
demanded that he get out of my car and then all
i could think of was i'm going to be murdered my
app wasn't out so i couldn't check this guy out
ahead of time and i'm going to be murdered and and
it's going to be just like the worst they're gonna
they're gonna just crucify me for letting a guy
in my car yeah i would never why would you like
a guy in your car well i wasn't thinking
i thought we were going to a coffee shop
around you know what i mean like i yeah this is
what happens when women are unwillingly celibate
for too long we make poor choices and this is
the other thing that the app is going to solve
because it will actually backstop these choices
and let it notify us if we're about to make a
poor choice are you sure you really want to make
this poor choice i think it's really interesting
i'm just so excited to see how people react to it
and how it takes off um it's going to be really
really interesting so do we have a timeline when
can we expect it being released i know you said
you had some trademark and copyright issues we
have a little trademark infringement going on that
we're trying to solve so uh hopefully that will be
done soon we will get the rebrand done and within
a couple of months the consent app will be out so
that's the plan and then once we hit density about
five to ten thousand users per city then
we'll open up the dating app in that city
because we want to make sure we have real users
so that's another thing and i don't know if you're
on clubhouse but i am we should do something on
clubhouse actually oh oh girlfriend oh yeah we
so should so i live on clubhouse but the way
that they did the onboarding it's exactly the
way that i had uh have in our plan for how we
do the onboarding which is somebody has to vouch
for you to get in yeah i think honestly i think
that's the smartest idea especially when it comes
to dating apps um i think this was the natural
evolution of dating apps and everybody hates them
but there's clearly a need for them um yes they
are shallow they don't it's just the nature
they don't have to be they don't have to be but
this is the natural evolution right and that's
okay and it's it's forever it's for some and it's
not for some and that's also fine so people don't
have to be upset and offended by it you know if
if it works for some then it works for some if
it doesn't then it doesn't um but what i will say
is no getting in cars with strangers none of that
i already got my butt kicked about
that one um probably about 400 comments
and they were like you know after the initial
shock of okay so you're still alive now let
me kick your ass so yeah i did literally
everything i've told everybody not to do but
you know again again if i can make mistakes like
that and i actually know what i'm doing uh imagine
other women who aren't quite so educated
in all of this and again unwilling celibacy
makes us make poor choices so i'd rather that the
choices be better right so this is my whole thing
when you've been unwillingly celibate for a long
time you get a little desperate that's the two
o'clock in the morning thing and you make four
choices at least with the app the choices that are
going to be available to you are quality choices
who are not going to stalk you not going to murder
you not going to be you know not going to be a
problem aren't going to give you anything safe
generally safe right so so i have a lot of
guy friends who are they're cute they got nice
bodies according to their ex-girlfriends they've
got great dick and they know how to use it
like they got they've got their vouched for um
they are not long-term material right they're just
for one reason or another like they're already
on the bachelor thing never getting married
never having kids whatever i'm like you say
that now until you meet your woman and then
you'll do the george clooney thing and get married
have twins so you know it but they're not gonna be
like the long-term person that suggested
but if you lower that down to a five
i have an entire stable of guys that
are absolutely perfect for a five
they're lovely they're kind they're funny you
know if you just need to cuddle and cry like
and then and have sex and then cuddle and cry like
there i got i got several who can handle that too
so that's i love it that's the whole
point it's like what exactly do you
need what do you want what do you need because
sometimes we really just need a naked cuddle
i love that you've built something based
off of what from your own experience and
from your own kind of needs and your own
what you feel is missing in the market and
it's also from a focus group of a thousand women
so it's not just my needs it is built that's where
the initial idea i mean yeah but it is built
for women by women the team is almost all women
uh four women by women about women so the
entire ai and the matching everything is
all based on how women think what they need
you know all that it's all based on women
it's not and none of the other apps are like
that at all they're all built like they're
just built from by men the oh my god this guy
came out with a consent app right after mine
and i was like are you [ __ ] me like is it is it
out and available what's it called it's like the
consent app or something like that it's terrible
it's a single part of it it's a single point of
consent it's just it's like it doesn't under the
whole they keep trying to steal the features like
i've had i've had eight of my key features like
co-oped by other dating apps that's nice and i'm
like yeah but they don't get it like they go
oh tinder we'll put in a panic button i'm like
yeah it goes deeper than that because
i'm not going to be able to reach
my phone and press a freaking panic button
yeah no i get it i guess to summarize it's
kind of it's consent on the blockchain
it's a i so you can find somebody that you want
either if it's for a night or for a long term
um and what would you say the third point is uh it
teaches people to have transparent communication
about what they really want so it's actually we
use a lot of nlp neuro-linguistic programming
to get people uh to shift their mindset and
really overcome some of their their issues
um so there's a lot of personal development
worked into it because in order to actually have
a successful long-term relationship you need to do
the work where can people find you follow you and
maybe ask to take you on a date oh lolly.io for
the app and at adrian a-d-r-y-e-n-n pretty much
everywhere perfect do you have any last thoughts
any last whatevers you want to share i'm single
my age range preference is somewhere between 35
and 70. i've got that big range because my former
husband is in his late 60s and my first boyfriend
after being single for nine years celibate for
seven was 28 and i was almost 50. he's now
30 but i think 35 is probably a better age
i'm not having any more children i'm a little
bit of a size queen uh i like smart sapiosexual
if they're not smart it's not going to happen so
scout for me pretty please there you go adrian
thank you so much i really appreciate you being
so honest and open with us and giving us the full
lowdown of what is going on thank you so much for
coming on thank you for having me again absolutely
and thanks everyone for watching i will see
you all next week on thursday at 12 p.m est bye